Trump will address the United Nations
General Assembly for the first time this
morning the White House says the
president speech will make a declaration
of American values the president is
expected to ask other nations to work
together to confront common threats and
dangers Margaret Brennan is at the UN
where one of mr. Trump's targets will be
front and center during his speech
Margaret good morning good morning well
North Korea will be seated right in the
front row as president Trump addresses
this gathering of nearly 200 leaders and
he will urge those countries to take
more responsibility for their own
security as part of his America first
world view but then he's going to ask
them for their help in confronting both
North Korea and Iran White House
officials say President Trump will be
extremely tough on the North Korean
Menace calling for a united front to
isolate Kim jong-un and his growing
nuclear arsenal the president is also
expected to pressure Iran to end its
support for terrorism and stop meddling
in the Middle East UN Ambassador nikki
Haley said mr. Trump will not avoid
confrontation he slaps the right people
he hugs the right people and he comes
out with us being very strong president
Trump indicated on Monday he may
withdraw from the international
agreement to freeze Iran's nuclear
program leadership it's a move supported
by Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu I look forward to discussing
with you how we can address together
what you rightly call is the terrible
nuclear deal with Iran but French
president emanuelle macron whose country
was at that negotiating table urged the
u.s. to remain committed to the Iran
deal the two leaders also discussed mr.
Trump's earlier decision to pull out of
the Paris climate agreement the United
States will cease all implementation of
the non-binding Paris Accord while
diplomacy is the president's focus this
week he again made known his affinity
for military might President Trump spoke
glowingly of his July trip to the Paris
Bastille Day Parade
we made you something
like that on July 4th in Washington now
White House officials say the president
will also pledge to take further action
against the regime in Venezuela if they
don't fully restore democracy Gail that
shows an interventionist message from a
president who up until now has really
articulated in America first
isolationist worldview all right Thank
You Margaret well I'll be watching today
thanks a lot